Путин
خطوط موسكو الحمراء وعلاقات
السعودية وامريكا على المحك فهل
حانت المواجهة? ودولة في الناتو
تحصل على طائرات انقرة في صفقة
هي الاولى من لاعضاء الحلف
وموسكو تطالب بالحق الفلسطيني
فاين العرب والتوتر الامريكي
الصيني يزداد والسبب روسيا في
زيارة لدولة عربية غير متوقعة
والعراق يأن من جراحه مجددا.
ساحات جديدة للحرب. معركة الغذاء
هي معركة النفس الطويل والفائز
من يضحك اخيرا معركة البقاء هذه.
هنا وزارة الدفاع الروسية تعلنها
وبعد الهجوم الذي نفذه نظام كييف
بمشاركة خبراء بريطانيين ضد سفن
اسطول البحر الاسود وسفن مدنية
تؤمن ممر الحبوب موسكو تعلق
مشاركتها في تنفيذ اتفاقات تصدير
المنتجات الزراعية من الموانئ
الاوكرانية بوتين يقطع شريان
اوروبا الغذائي بعد شريان
الطاقة. فهل وقت الاستسلام ليرد
البيت الابيض ان انسحاب موسكو من
اتفاق تصدير الحبوب يؤكد
استخدامها الغذاء كسلاح بينما
قال زلينسكي تعليق روسيا اتفاق
الحبوب يتطلب ردا دوليا قويا.
فعن اي رد تتحدث ومن ساحة الغذاء
الى ساحات الوغى. حيث تتعدد
الساحات والحرب واحدة والخصوم هم
ذاتهم في كل مرة. درب موحد تحت
لواء الولايات المتحدة وخصم روسي
عنيد يأبى الا ان يصل لجميع
اهدافه هنا وعلى موعد ممتد من
الازمات السياسية مولدوفا في
حيرة من امرها، فكلما تصاعدت
وتيرة الحرب الروسية الاوكرانية
زادت مخاوف النظام في مولدوفا من
تكرار سيناريو اوكرانيا معها،
وبحسب واشنطن بوست فروسيا قد
ارسلت فريقا من الاستراتيجيين
السياسيين الروس لتقديم المشورة
لحزب المعارضة المولدوفي. فهل
حان وقت فتح جبهة اخرى بين موسكو
والغرب ومن جبهة مولدوفا الى
الجبهة الاكثر اشتعالا لكن هذه
المرة بين واشنطن والرياض.
فالعلاقة بين الولايات المتحدة
والمملكة العربية السعودية هي
واحدة من اهم العلاقات خصوصا بعد
روسي سعودي جعل الامريكان
يستعيرون غضبا. لقد فوجئت الرياض
بتعطش السياسيين الامريكيين
للانتقام ويلمح السعوديون الى
الرد بما في ذلك عبر سندات
الخزانة الامريكية والذي يمكن ان
يكون له اثار مضاعفة هائلة
بالاسواق المالية والاقتصاد
الحقيقي. فهل تشعل السعودية
التوترات اكثر بها جبهة اخرى
تفتحها تركيا لكن الخصم هنا هي
روسيا. ورغم التهديدات الروسية
بضرب اي مصنع للطائرات المسيرة
في اوكرانيا واعتباره هدفا
مشروعا كشفت شركة الصناعات
العسكرية التركية بايكار عن
استكمال خططها لافتتاح مصنع
للطائرات المسيرة في اوكرانيا
وخلال عامين فكيف سترد موسكو?
وهنا بولندا على مسيرات برقدار
التركية لتصبح اول دولة في
الناتو والاتحاد الاوروبي تحصل
على هذا النوع من الطائرات
المسيرة بينما خرج الامين العام
لحلف الناتو يمس توتنبرج ليحذران
خفض الدعم الامريكي لاوكرانيا لن
يؤدي الا الى تمكين الصين كونه
يعطي بكين اشارة بانه يمكنها
استخدام القوة لتحقيق اهدافها.
ومن حرب التصريح الى الحرب
العالمية الثالثة. لكن قبل ذلك
اعلن الرئيس الشيشاني رمضان
قديروف مقتل ثلاثة وعشرين واصابة
ثمانية وخمسين من قواته في قصف
مدفعي اوكراني في مقاطعة خرسون.
واضاف قديروف ان القوات الخاصة
الشيشانية تمكنت من قتل اكثر من
سبعين اوكرانيا ردا على القصف
متوعدا بالانتقام من القوات
الاوكرانية. يخرج على العلن
الاقتصادي الامريكي الذي تنبأ
بازمة عام الفين وثمانية ويعلن
ان الحرب العالمية الثالثة قد
بدأت بالفعل. وقال في حديث
لصحيفة شبيجل الالمانية يعبر
مستشارو الامن القومي عن قلقهم
من تدخل حلف الناتو في النزاع
الاوكراني. كما نشهد خلافات حادة
في العلاقات بين ايران واسرائيل
واقرأ في الصباح ان ادارة بايدن
تتوقع ان الصين ستهاجم تايوان
قريبا بصراحة فان الحرب العالمية
الثالثة قد بدأت بالفعل وتنتشر
اعمالها في المجال السيبراني وفي
اوكرانيا. لكن ما يقرب الحرب
اكثر هو اعلان الدفاع الروسية ان
البحرية البريطانية شاركت في
تخطيط وتنفيذ عمل ارهابي استهدف
خطي بالغاز نورد ستريم وان وتو
في سبتمبر الماضي. فماذا ان صح
هذا الخبر لتصوب روسيا انظار
العالم الى ناحية اخرى؟ نعم انها
فلسطين بقول ممثلي روسيا لدى
الامم المتحدة فاسيليني بنزيا ان
الولايات المتحدة والاتحاد
الاوروبي يحاولان صرف انتباه
المجتمع الدولي عن الصراعات
الاقليمية بما فيها الصراع
الفلسطيني ويضيف المجلس مدين حقا
للفلسطينيين. فيما تصب الولايات
المتحدة الزيت على النار مرة
اخرى باعلان البنتاجون تقديم
حزمة مساعدات عسكرية جديدة
لاوكرانيا بقيمة مائتين وخمسة
وسبعين مليون دولار من جانبها
فرضت كندا عقوبات جديدة على
افراد وشركات روسية. فهل تأكد
تنبؤ روبين بعد كل هذه الاحداث
لكن وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجي
جويجو يعلن انتهاء عمليات
التعبئة الجزئية في البلاد
باستدعاء ثمانمائة الف شخص ممن
سبقت خدمتهم في القوات المسلحة
مشيرا الى ان اثنين وثمانين الف
مجند شملتهم التعبئة الجزئية
باتوا في منطقة الصراع اوكرانيا
مع وجود مائتين وثمانية عشر الفا
في التدريبات ليرد الاوكراني
قائلا القوات الروسية تعاني من
ضعف شديد في التحضير والعتاد وهو
ما يدفعنا للاعتقاد بان روسيا قد
تحتاج قريبا لافواج جديدة من
المجندين الذين سيرسلون الى
الحرب. هنا صحيفة بوليتكو
الامريكية فرنسا والمانيا
تعتزمان مطالبة واشنطن بتخفيف
اجراءاتها لخفض تضخم والعودة
لمبدأ المنافسة العادلة بينما
تجري تظاهرات حاشدة في التشيك
تطالب باستقالة الحكومة وتنتقد
الاتحاد الاوروبي والناتو وعمال
المعادن يبدأون اضرابا تحذيريا
من اجل زيادة الاجور في المانيا
واوروبا في ازمة اقتصادية
وسياسية فعلية يا سادة. بكين
تعلنها لواشنطن. التوترات على
اشدها والعلاقات بين واشنطن
وبكين بين كفي عفريت ليعلن اصحاب
العيون الضيقة روسيا كاقوى حليف
شاء من شاء وابى من ابى. ويبدو
ان التوتر الصيني الامريكي مستمر
في التصاعد وان الفجوة بين
البلدين لن تضيق قريبا. حيث اكدت
الصين دعمها القوي لروسيا في
توقيت تشهد فيه العلاقات بين
البلدين تقاربا يثير قلق
الولايات المتحدة وحلفائها ليعلن
وزير الخارجية الصيني لنظيره
الروسي خلال اتصال هاتفي مساندة
بكين لموسكو من اجل تجاوز الصعاب
وتعزيز مكانة روسيا كقوة عظمى.
كما حثت بكين واشنطن التخلي عن
ما سمتها عقلية الحرب الباردة.
ومنطق الهيمنة لتقولها بكين
وبصوت عال محاولة لمنع الصين
وروسيا من المضي قدما محكوم
عليها بالفشل. الصينيون لا
يتوقفون. وهنا تحقيق لشبكة سكاي
نيوز يكشف استمرار تدريب سلاح
الجو البريطاني لطيارين صينيين
كما تم السماح لمواطنين صينيين
بالدراسة في الكليات العسكرية
لبريطانيا بحسب ما قالت الشبكة.
الاحداث تطورات. مصادر طبية
وامنية عراقية ثمانية قتلى واكثر
من عشرين جريحا بانفجار قرب ملعب
شعبي في حي البنوك شمال شرقي
بغداد. المغرب يرحب بتمديد بعثة
مينوروسو والبوليساريو المدعومة
من الجزائر تهدد بالتصعيد
العسكري. اعلن البيت الابيض ان
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن سيزور
كلا من مصر بوديا واندونيسيا
خلال الفترة من الحادي عشر حتى
السادس عشر من نوفمبر المقبل.
معركة اخرى هي الغذاء وساحة اخرى
تفتتح وحرب اخرى توشك على
الاندلاع وتبقى روسيا الخصم في
كل الاحوال للولايات المتحدة.
والعالم ينتظر متى ستندلع الحرب
الحقيقية بين موسكو وواشنطن.